this is I think what we should really be
talking about that new Johnny Depp movie
Black Mass opened this past weekend
there's that yeah black masses said you
know about whitey Bulger's supposed to
be this you know great crime drama blah
blah blah blah I don't care I'm angry
about this movie alright and I'll tell
you why look at the poster again there's
the actual poster right now zoom in on
the actor in the center red square right
there that's joel edgerton right there
or does he look familiar to you ladies
and gentlemen
[Applause]
[Music]
this guy stole my face I know he stole
my face he clearly paid hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of dollars to get
this beautiful puss worth every penny
well worth every penny I have so many
people telling me that guys that you in
that postern I'm like no no no why would
I be a tough guy in a gangster that'll
be the worst gangster movie of all time
you had all these tough guys and then I
came in the room and I'm like yeah
that's what we're gonna do wasn't that a
great clip subscribe to my youtube
channel for an endless supply of me
[Laughter]